here here's here's a big a big big
problem i see
what do you do with the money when you
get it let's say you're somebody who uh
you get stimulus check you bought a
bunch of uh you know stock of some sort
it skyrockets you're a millionaire
what do you do with all that money i
guess you could buy a house the problem
is
the housing market's insane people are
buying property side and scene we
mentioned earlier in the show
there's a wapo story about a house that
sold from a million dollars over asking
just because people are like i don't
care how to buy the house
so sure you make a quick million bucks
off doge or gamestop or amc
what do you buy with it what can you buy
with it we've been waiting for over
two months to get a new computer for the
studio
had to order it when you did an upgrade
and they're like sorry we're all out of
chips like what's gonna wait i guess
so i think what's happening is it's good
news for the little guy in a certain
sense
it may be bad news for everybody in the
long run you've got people who are
making tons of money
and there's a reason why they're putting
it right back in what else they're going
to do with it
i think for them because they started
pretty close to zero many many people
they're just like well let's see how big
i can get it for like they just
the joke is when lambo but they're
basically describing like when do i get
life-changing money and i mean just
anecdotally i don't have the stats on it
but like
the thing i hear is i finally paid off
my student debt
i finally paid off my mortgage i finally
am not begging
verizon to keep my internet on and like
and then other ones it's like
very sad like i mean when i started this
you project yourself on it i'm 26
i thought it was fun i was in on the bet
and then i s
through this platform that i've been so
fortunate to have
like you get real stories like some
people were reaching out to me of just
super super sad things of like i was
financially stuck in abusive
relationship and i can finally leave
that
and like that just resonates like i
started this for the lows and the jokes
but like seeing what it's become and
like positively impact it and i get what
you're saying about like certain
material things
but i think um just how on like a deeply
human level how upset people have been
like with how their life has been going
they view they're clinging on to hope
and i think that cling on to hope
is the exact reason why these hedge
funds they're not going to end up
winning it because i think they're
undervaluing people's ambitions to hold
on that it starts as the joke but when
you like
really unpack the psychology of it i
just don't see how they end up winning
this particular one
i think uh a lot of this is
evidence to to state that the us dollar
is going to collapse
to it to some degree meaning it'll exist
i'm not saying it will cease to exist
but uh if you've got people who are
getting millions of dollars and then
just putting it right back in
if you've got hedge funds now joining in
and people don't want to work
what's the value of a dollar if you
can't buy something with it so
if somebody's got millions of dollars in
stock
they don't need a job if people are
getting paid by the government
unemployment checks bonuses they don't
need to work
if you can't even buy the playstation
you want then what am i looking forward
to with working anyway my bills are
covered
so what happens then is the ultra
wealthy the hedge funds who are like
we've got a billion dollars
what do we do with it nobody wants to
work we can offer people more and more
and more money they still won't take the
jobs
the money has no value if people don't
want it that's what that's the value of
the currencies the confidence behind it
but
anything really so it seems like right
now a lot of people have more faith in
amc's
stock not even necessarily as a company
just like the meme stocks
then they do the actual u.s dollars to
do something with oh yeah and i think
that's why
what we saw playing out with dogecoin
why it happened it's like i'd rather
take that bet
and whether people are actively paying
attention to it or not you alluded to it
before
the inflation is incredible like the can
we are kicking down the road is way
beyond a can we are rolling a
barrel of oil and there's like a flame
right behind it it's just the
the on policy of unlimited quantitative
easing
i get it at a high level of like let's
help out with unemployment let's just
see if we can assist with it but the
degree the magnitude to which it's like
surpass 2008 and 2009
it's just unlimited currency of course
it's gonna devalue it
and then like i'm sure you guys are
better to comment on like then what it
changes
in competition to the yen and that stuff
like there are serious political
global ramifications of the actions and
i'm by no means an
economic expert but like i'm at least
smart enough to recognize it's not good
yeah i think uh i'm not gonna tell
anybody what they should or shouldn't do
i don't give financial advice on the
show but i'm buying crypto
oh yeah i'm buying crypto man i was
reading uh what was i reading today well
for one we saw recently goldman sachs
announced
they're like you know oh crypto's a new
you know key asset or whatever an asset
to
uh i wrote a class an asset class so
they're like telling people like
this is something you want to buy and
bitcoin is decentralized
it's uh it's possible but you know
extremely difficult
to to manipulate i'm you know there's
there's things you can do like with what
elon musk did
but i look at what the rich people are
doing and i'm like they're preparing for
something
you know there there was a there's a uh
mountain bunkers in like new zealand do
you guys ever hear about this
rich people have like landing strips and
mountainsides
like d-day bunkers almost yeah so like
the apocalypse happens like an appliance
like why not
man if you're worth you think bezos
doesn't have a fallout vault
why wouldn't he it definitely does like
a seed vault
you have that arctic seed vault they
have small bird
no no yeah yeah i think it is yes in
svalbard uh and i don't think
i i mean maybe i'm saying straight up
like what if i was jeff bezos i would
literally
make like a a vault-tec vault i'd be
like just you know i don't want to do an
experiments like they do in the game
just want to have a regular vault so
build it why wouldn't they but they do
they do have things like this
they sell like missile silos that have
been converted into homes you can like
you go down like 16 or 20 stories
whatever so anyway rich people have
prepared for a lot of really crazy
things
but now you look at what's going on with
cryptocurrency yeah the ultra wealthy
are buying into it big
and they're manipulating it big right so
elon musk pulled a really shady move
he announces hey we're going to be doing
bitcoin bitcoin for tesla i think that
was this year right
yeah when he says we're going to do
bitcoin for tesla then he gets a bunch
of bitcoin and then announces we're not
going to do it anymore
then the value drops but what happened
the people who were selling the crypto
were poor people
they were essentially the retail
investors people who had a couple
hundred bucks here and there
who panicked when they saw it collapsing
and like oh no elon musk doesn't want to
use it anymore oh no square says they're
not going to use it
so they all sell guess who who buys it
up the rich people
the rich people buy it all up and then
after that dip
goldman sachs comes out and they're like
oh by the way we're going to recommend
all of our
you know wealthy clients buy more into
this so i'm like i look at what they're
doing
i wouldn't necessarily uh uh do
everything they've done you know
shorting gamestop seemed to have been a
very bad idea
at amc but it all i also wonder if what
they're doing with crypto manipulation
is to cover their losses like a lot of
these hedge funds are like
if we go belly up it's going to be 2008
all over again
what can we do and it's like well let's
steal the money from poor people through
cryptocurrency and use it to cover our
losses
it's one of those things that like on my
end of it it's hard to like
tie things exactly together unless
you're the one executing the trade
but we really commonly see the opposite
moves as if they're trying to cover
margin requirements liquidity calls in
other markets and that stuff there's
been
and it's an easier asset class to move
money to wash money through like
you do see weird things and i'm like
maybe at that point i'm putting on my
tinfoil hat but like
it's i don't know it just seems very
very realistic
how can they you know i've got two two
views on this
how could a regular person think that
they're going to be able to beat the
hedge funds
who have got friends in government
covering their asses at the same time
i wonder how can the hedge funds think
they're going to go up against 3.2
million regular people who can just
flood the zone with cash and shut them
out
yeah it's hard to know which way it's
going to go i mean you could always have
um i mean one thing we haven't touched
on is at the start of february
the brokerages just stopped the buying
and everyone's like you can
right robin's been shut down not just
almost all of them right
robin hood i guess became the symbol of
it just because of their name they're
like it doesn't seem like you're robin
hood that's pretty weird robin poor
yeah but um they were robbing from us
but they stopped it and everyone's like
whoa whoa whoa like
whatever we've been pitched of this
concept of the free market really
that seems super not free market hey man
like what's going on
and we're not like the way the legal
system moves it's so slow and like right
now there are certain federal
and state-wide cases against robin hood
but you hope it doesn't happen again but
we're about to find out most likely and
we'll see but
the amount of distrust in the system
at large whether it's the political
system the economic system
i feel like it's growing and like i
don't know like at my age maybe i just
haven't seen enough maybe it's been
worse at other times
but the times that i've been actively
paying attention to it
it does seem like it's up-taking of just
like the underlying
anger and distrust for our systems how
much of this is just greed
just people like i'm gonna turn my page
i'm gonna double my paycheck right now
you know what i mean like
you go you work you get a couple hundred
bucks or i mean a lot of people aren't
working but let's say you did work and
you got paid a thousand bucks you're
like whatever i'll put in an amc for the
week
pull it out back at 2000 right i mean
very possible but i could also argue
it's greed the other way of why do they
keep shorting it they think they're so
right and they're trying to make money
about driving a company into the ground
it's just i mean i think everyone's in
it for self-benefit
it's just like you're going to argue
your point stronger you look at
crypto's a really good example of the
great i think because we get super chats
all the time
and it's like you know tim you've really
got to look into this particular
cryptocurrency
and it's called like you know
flobblecoin or something it's like i've
never heard of this
it's worth like point zero zero zero
zero one of a cent
and then and it's like i personally have
14 billion of these coins so like
everybody's gotta get it it's the new
thing and i'm like is it the new thing
or is it just the one you bought and you
want everyone to buy in so you can cash
out
yeah i mean i i think i even experienced
a little bit of that after the dodge run
up
like everything seemed to be like they
even pitches that they're like oh it's
just another meme one like
they were trying to hop into it and it i
always took the argument that it's very
difficult to recreate a perfect storm
but man if if gme was one it seems like
the community at large is about to pull
it off with amc again
they to some degree pulled it off with
doge and we don't even know if that
storyline is really over
like the same thing it went up might be
taking a breather sell out a new price
and then rip again
like you just don't know but it seems
like all the changes and maybe it's
because of technology
it happens so much more rapidly and uh
at
just like the ferocity of it it's just
such a greater magnitude of like just
the the swings up and down just across
the board
it's it's it is it's nuts like i'm
watching the
like my stocks and i'm like if i was
perfectly trading like here's the peak
cell like here's the the dip
buy you'd be making like millions per
day
oh yeah just like it's an exponential
increase the more money you make the
more
you do and eventually you get so big
you're actually swaying the market
yourself with your buying and you're
selling
like the act of buying the dip makes it
spike up and then you when other people
get fomo and buy in you sell yeah that's
it's just
you know watching cryptocurrency prices
where it's like 42
33 37 i'm like man people are becoming
billionaires off this
yeah the ones who who are pulling off
those trades perfectly
i i can't i can't see man how an economy
like this works
i i don't understand it it seems like
it's
we're not completely off the rails but
it feels like the train is kind of
shaking
of it it's starting to get there it's
like really picking up but
i wonder that it's like one of those
things like maybe should i just started
the economy for like five decades of my
life and i'm like oh this happens every
so often
or is it a legitimate shift in the
direction that we're actually going like
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time